les palestiniens ne manqueront pas de
date cette année le 22 mai les
législatives suivies par la
présidentielle le 31 juillet une annonce
importante faite par le président
mahmoud abbas quinze ans que ces
scrutins n'ont pas pu se tenir dans les
territoires palestiniens et dans la
bande de gaza quinze ans de divisions
entre le fatah et le hamas
les mouvements palestiniens rivaux sont
restés à couteau tiré jusqu'au mois de
septembre dernier moment où ils ont
enfin pu s'entendre sur l'organisation
d'élections
une évolution saluée par le fatah et le
hamas le hamas se félicite de la
publication de décret présidentiel
relatifs à la conduite des élections
législatives présidentielle et du
conseil national la masse a travaillé
pendant de nombreux mois à la
préparation du climat national afin que
nous soyons prêts pour des élections
sérieuse ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est
engager un dialogue national afin de
trouver toutes les solutions nécessaires
pour un véritable processus électoral
qui exprime la volonté de notre peuple
palestinien mahmoud abbas a promis la
tenue d'élections à plusieurs reprises
sans jamais concrétiser sa promesse
pourtant pour beaucoup de gazaouis la
tenue de ces scrutins re donnerait plus
de légitimité aux dirigeants
palestiniens si vous demandez à
quiconque dans la rue il vous dira
qu'ils souhaitent une élection tant que
l'élu prend soin de nous et répond à nos
demandes
parce qu'ici nous avons été malmenés
quel que soit le parti élu que ce soit
pour la présidence où le conseil
législatif l'important est qu'il y ait
des élections que la situation
économique change et améliore la vie de
tous tant qu'il n'ya pas de
réconciliation entre le fatah et le
hamas
les élections sont impossibles car s'il
y avait une réconciliation
il y aurait un accord entre les deux
parties en tant que gazaouis je veux que
les élections mettre fin à la division
entre le fatah et le hamas
une rupture entre les deux mouvements
palestiniens qui remonte à 2007 année où
le ramasse prend le contrôle de la bande
de gaza au prix d'un putsch armés à
l'origine de cette décision
la victoire du hamas aux législatives
des élections qui on veut ni mais les
relations entre les deux camps depuis la
vie politique palestinienne est figé et
beaucoup espèrent retrouver le droit de
choisir leurs dirigeants et
représentants